When I work with data-bind in Knockout, I often get it a little bit wrong, and
sometimes it feels discouraging.
So, if that happened to you during this exercise, it's not you.
It comes with the territory.
And the best programmers can keep their chin up and
keep working at it despite things breaking.
Also, your solution may look different from mine.
That's also okay.
There are many ways of doing this.
So, look at my solution more for inspiration rather than for the right answer.
That said, here's my solution.
First, I added an observable array in my ViewModel.
I also chose some of the cutest nicknames ever, Tabitha Tab Tabby Catty Cat.
Now, in the HTML, as you can see, I've added a div down here for our nicknames,
an h3 to make it look pretty, and I made a ul with a foreach binding.
This will take this li and do it again and
again and again for each of the nicknames.
And these li's have a text binding of $data.
Now, I used $data because I had to get to the actual data in the array that
we're looping over.
Now, this is great for simple things like nicknames or months or
lottery numbers where the data is super simple, just a string or
a number or Boolean for that matter.
Now, if you filled your observable array with objects on the other hand,
you would write the name of the property that you wanted out of the object.
This is great when you're looping over objects that are a bit more complicated,
maybe objects that represent people or products.
But in this case, it's just a bunch of strings.